all right well we have to leave you we
got somebody more important my boy aaron
jones how are you doing hey we get aaron
jones you get a mod hey man how's
everything let me take you back to the
beginning of this game what were you
thinking when you fell behind ten
nothing in that first quarter just come
out and make a play get up on the board
and uh we we knew it would end up
swinging some one way or another
what's the what's the most difficult
part about coming off a bye trying to
play in a game like this
uh you just
a little rush you know that's what i
feel like a little russ you you you
don't have that week of practice that
you have that well two weeks ago you
know um you're just coming back people
were coming back off the planes their
vacations or whatever it may be but
i'm glad we came out here we didn't
start as fast as we wanted to but second
half we started fast talk about aaron
rodgers man and what he's shown you i
mean his toughness coming out if anybody
ever had a toe they know how difficult
it is to run not only run play
quarterback and in these
frigid temperatures he's a he's a true
warrior he's our leader and we go as he
goes you know uh he may not practice
during the week but he lets us know hey
i'm gonna be there game day he's he's
out there with us at practice he's
pushing us he's he's making sure we're
getting everything right leadership
leadership and uh when you got a great
leader like that everything's gonna be
good man you look like you fly a
spaceship wearing those shades right
there yeah walking through that design
walking through that design one time
what you got there uh these are oakley
cato so okay um these are these are the
new versions this year there you go the
gold versions they were only haunted out
to the olympians uh who won a medal so
uh i was lucky lucky enough to get a
pair man you got to talk to me about aj
dylan now it seems like you've been
working with aj dylan because it doesn't
seem like they changed the playbook when
they put you or or him in oh yes sir
we've been putting in a lot of work uh
and that's that's one thing that we want
we don't want when when he comes in or
when i come in it's predictable right
you can't get a beat on us you don't
know what's going on he can do the same
things that i can and i can do the same
things that he can uh it's been an honor
to work with him and he's getting better
and better each game and what about that
fourth quarter how nice is it to have
him in the fourth quarter and really
wear down that defense in the fourth
quarter the bruiser is real nice
in the fourth quarter they they worn
down they'll want to tackle him
that's 250 running at you
he don't want to do that
and then partnership with your twin
brother alvin you get the nod for walter
payton man of the year one of the
coolest awards that the nfl does what
has your brother meant to your football
journey and your life journey too my
brother has meant everything uh
especially after my my father's past
my brother contemplated giving up
football and just being there for me
but i told him no you know what that's
that's your dream don't give up on your
dream and that wouldn't want you to give
up on your dream uh but that's just a
little bit about my brother he's he's
he's everything to me he
only gained these misses when he was up
in the cfl he's been here every step of
the way um he's been the thing he's one
of the reasons that i keep going and he
pushes me for me it's a pretty special
place i played here but to look up in
the raptors and see ray nitzke and bart
starr how does it feel for you to see
all these fans yelling and screaming
supporting aaron jones bro we got the
best fans in the world i i can't say
nothing but we got the best fans in the
world
uh i love playing here in lambeau the
tradition is nothing like it and like i
said the best fans in the world and you
got this incredible partnership
friendship as well with aaron rodgers
how has pairing with him impacted your
career
uh it's made me the player i am today uh
it wasn't for a-rod i didn't even know
if i would have seen the field i
remember
when i was young my rookie year he
turned to the cell line i won 33 in the
game and uh i remember running on on the
uh running to the game my first time is
actually against the bears week four of
my rookie year and he tells me i'm one
of your biggest fans in this
organization and i'm like wow in a
future hall of fame quarterbacks telling
me that that's a rookie
it made me feel like i could could
accomplish anything and um it gave me a
lot of confidence you know as like i
said a future hall of famers telling a
rookie who hadn't taken a a single
offense to snap this and
uh it's definitely
done a lot for me in my career well we
we really appreciate you coming by man
we're not going to hold you out here we
know you got business to take care of
thank you for that yeah and i'm a huge
fan of you oh thank you man i'm here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports